des fils barbelés des barrières
métalliques et des soldats lourdement
armées la cafore la force
d'interposition de l'OTAN n'a pas lésiné
sur les moyens pour assurer le calme
dans le nord du Kosovo toute la journée
des militants servent on fait le siège
devant les mairies de svetjan et de
l'épo-savitch pour protester contre
l'élection de maire albanais dans ces
villes très majoritairement certes des
scrutins qui considèrent illégitime et
pour cause boycotté par les Serbes le
taux de participation dépassait de la
peine les 3%.
l'ancien merde promet de revenir tous
les jours tant que c'est demain ne
seront pas entendus
dans la ville les rues autour de la
mairie portent encore les traces des
manifestations de la veille
les violences affrontements entre des
militants herbes et les membres de la
CAFOR ont fait plus de 80 blessés
une trentaine de soldats hongrois et
italiens dont certains dans un état
grave et une cinquantaine de
manifestants des débordements qui ont
encore fait monter d'un cran attention
entre les autorités serbes et celles du
Kosovo
à Belgrade le président serbe Alexander
routchich a mis l'armée sur un pied
d'alerte et à blâmer son homologue
kosovar pour foudre la communauté
internationale doit ramener Albin
courtier à la raison du style
majoritaires dans le nord du Kosovo
demande depuis longtemps une plus grande
autonomie comme prévu dans un accord
européen qui date de 2013 iPhone de
mental
une éventualité que rejette le Premier
ministre du Kosovo qui revendique la
souveraineté surtout les territoires
a déclaré son indépendance de la Serbie
en 2008 10 ans après une guerre
meurtrière une indépendance reconnue par
une centaine de pays dans le monde mais
qui est toujours contesté par les Serbes
par les Russes et les Chinois
les appels au calme se multiplient le
chef de la diplomatie européenne
rappelle qu'il y a déjà assez de
violence sur le continent que l'Europe
ne peut pas se permettre un autre
conflit oui
avec force par le secrétaire général de
l'otense
700 soldats supplémentaires de la cafe
et de mettre sur un pied d'alerte un
bataillon de réserve prêt à être déployé
en cas de besoin l'objectif est de
prévenir un conflit armé mais sur le
fond des choses l'impasse demeure et les
extrémistes dans chaque camp continue de
monopoliser la conversation et si
Jean-François Bélanger Radio-Canada
Montréal